um
so i spent 15 hours drawing with a
ballpoint pen and you'll probably never
see it but i hope you like
it i think he will see it
the only logical outcome of this photo
how did you know
[Laughter]
god
[Laughter]
yes yes yes yes and maya is the one that
took the photo that's basically what
happened
how's it going bronze welcome to laura
we
look at memes and go haha leave your
memes on the reddit 19 year old
now measure your peeps in the last
episode
oh my god see this is what i expected
from the first meme that's why i had
barely no reaction to it
pewdiepie as firebender fan art 57
upvote
i drew myself holding a piece of fan art
i made
[Music]
three million members god damn i wanted
my mother
now what the hell did i just say bill
delphine box
incoming who should i send a mystery box
to next
how do i even go about contacting
pewdiepie that's how she speaks by the
way
i really want to give him a mystery box
but how how can i give him cyber morton
i mean hi sup
cyborg martin my own editor
my own flesh and wound
i say no i don't all right
listen this is not a dish against belly
belly belly deli
belly deadly philly i don't want i don't
want it i'm done
don't send me stuff i don't care who you
are if elon musk says hey felix you won
no no no i don't want your stop
i don't care no let me just live
an empty life with nothing can i is that
too much to ask
a new look for my taxi by the way i'm a
nine-year-old taxi driver
works in cash a blanket damn they let
you start working early in casablanca
huh
god damn that looks good god damn
aren't you a bit too young to drive a
taxi
[Laughter]
imagine entering that taxi holy hell
dude you're [ __ ] nine year old
hey yeah i'm nine that's amazing
that's crazy well my post got deleted
for the fourth time
[Music]
see i can be a japanese anime voice
sector
bro bro fist me all right
how about this i'll send you a package
instead is that huh you have to have
this knock off
pewdiepie merch at least you kind of got
the real one
[Music]
all right i'll i'll we'll we'll do that
yeah yeah okay guys how do i even go
about contacting belly belly deli
i really want to give her a mystery box
but how
let's make 2020 the worst year ever did
i say that
oh my god i said it in january it's all
my fault
i did it careful what you wish for god
damn it
oh no i'm so sorry guys i [ __ ] that
one up didn't i
god damn it what is that streak in my
goddamn mirror what is that it looks
like someone just
i like it oh dear i'm literally shaking
with happiness it happened i got
on the why i got huge pv for pirate
party little thank you for support
and pee pees this recognition by pierce
meant the world to me he spotted the
jurgen merch a true man of his own
culture
true man of his own culture indeed
that's funny huge pp yet again again
anything to spread libertarianism to the
kids
to the kids are pewdiepie submissions
wait they're all simps always has been
yeah this is literally what i said at
the start disgusted
i thought i trained you better you know
better danny
insert title here lasagna 257
jake paul is every day bro 270.
90 rows assemble go out there
go out there and do your how do you do
it
okay okay nine-year-olds go out there
and do your thing
come on nine-year-olds do it wow how did
he get like that
every time i apologize i do one push-up
jesus christ oh yeah i haven't done an
apology i'm sorry guys
i don't have an apology this week i know
it's terrible i'm sorry wait a minute
i just i just apologize what
felix to his fans he likes too much
no i'm not a simp shut up shut up
[Laughter]
ah god i'm good
yes yes yes yes yes i knew it i bought
sorry science i always i'm not gonna say
that i've always had my sneaking
suspicion but
i always had my sneaking suspicion last
week i didn't ask
you but you did post some crap images
which i have to review now
pretty much accurate truth the subreddit
has gone to shh
now where's all the fan art where is it
honey wait it isn't cocoa melon never
has been
got him hey there it is pewdiepie
submission has a three million
celebration what are you going to do not
be a simp
rpd5 submission hits 3 million sub
members
reddit admins knowing we're one of the
busiest subreddits
on reddit is that true hey
congratulations
it's a celebration buddy
waiting oh dude we're so low dude
there we are 85 [ __ ] all right
photography
we're coming for you ass boy take your
shitty photos and go somewhere else
overwatch yeah
reaction games pizzas i [ __ ] think so
[ __ ] you reaction gifts animals being
bros
get the flip out of here you're done
when jax decides he doesn't want his mic
back pewds
oh finally uh yeah he took it back
he said stuff dude he said this in uh
irish noises i was trying to interpret
it could not understand
irish noises could not make sense of
them so glad
i grew up with this and not this so glad
and now i'm watching this
apology accepted oh thank you little
toddler
i've never cried in my life yeah just
because i looked sad and had
water coming from my ears eyes
does not mean i cried what the [ __ ]
cringe oh god what is this
now you say that forehead though god
damn
i could take a mom come on
irish flag whatever the [ __ ] he's from
guatemala whatever that country is
sweden i don't know anyone that afraid
to read it
maya 72 years older than most appealed
subs
and [ __ ] badass with one eye the
queen herself
take care of me edgar tambouwin
terribly noisy
yeah that's right stinky edgar you're
nothing
you protect it this is so accurate this
is the most accurate move i've ever read
on this subreddit
god damn have pewdiepie perform
congratulations for sweden at eurovision
you son of a [ __ ] i mean all right sure
let's make it happen why not
air whoa
all right long ago
all four gangs live together in harmony
then everything changed when the feeling
gang attacked
only the avatar master of all four gangs
could stop them
but when the world needed him most he
vanished
a hundred years passed and my brother
and i discovered the news
a floor gang member named pewdiepie and
although his tambourine playing skills
were great he has a lot to learn before
he is ready to defeat kokomo
but i believe pewdiepie can save the
world
now this i'll watch fine all right i'll
watch avatar so much you want me to
watch okay
all right that was amazing well done i
like that
pewds apology videos
didn't i milk markiplier one time i
don't think about it
does that mean i started the milk meme
say i milked markiplier
i'm the original milker i'm the milker
i'm the one that melts
i am the one that milks rise up gamer
boys
it's time to get your gamer girl condoms
do i look like i have sex
oh that's funny because virgins
[ __ ] virgins you know what i don't
like philadelphia so much maybe i don't
because she shares the same audience as
coco melons
they're obviously all still virgins i
knew it
the most important thing in life can't
be bought with money
food water true true when the game
releases a new skin for free
everybody be looking the same i know i
know when someone asked me when did i
become a pewds fan
before the dark times all right yeah
sure
me damn i miss pew's live stream oh well
i'll just re-watch it now youtube it's
this video member only i feel my heart
cry per game me trying to find a
girlfriend edit found one
why am i plotting goddamn sim rtx
off rtx on
yes yes yes yes yes i need my white
blonde hair back
come on as an indian 19 year old i
really appreciate people's making
efforts to acknowledge
made soul rest in peace it's time to go
which is a good actor no
you were a great actor and most
importantly a great person and deserve
much better
big peepee right there pigs thank you
very much to sean to you as well
there are no accidents not timing though
i didn't notice that that's funny
my amazing girlfriend made this for my
birthday
what a simp oh my god
you eat cake that's so cringe bro
that's a really cool cookie oh meredith
science
bon jovi on this day four years ago
beast master 64 left us in search of gay
righteous and never came back
he was like father to us it's been that
long huh how tall is pewdiepie
180 felix height one point how did
you get 175.3 like that
is so wrong why the decimal if you
ah i'm not short we also want the
shopping cart to be like
true truth whoa
what is this this is a gif
[Music]
hell yeah that's dope big peepee
manga anime wholesome adaptation
cute
why is there a two in the middle of this
mustang
i don't know i don't know top scientist
still trying to investigate did he still
see it it wasn't just the light in the
other yeah yeah
this is the sad truth is i can never
grow a proper
charlie chaplin mustache yeah that's
what i meant
[Music]
you tried and i appreciate the effort of
trying
jack watching this sexually harassed his
mic
it's okay you can keep the microphone
felix that's what he was trying to say
wow damn
that's dope i like that one review of
the video boss
thank you thank you
i'm sorry jack i'm sorry
wait is this the fitness and ferb one
hell yeah
[Music]
title sequence what
what god damn
[Laughter]
dude quit youtube edgar take over i'm
okay with this
damn this one's so cool
damn that's wallpaper worthy god damn i
love it
so cool
[Laughter]
now that's fan art not that scary
uh is this a meme on people that add
themselves to the photo
of their artwork amazing well done there
it is i drew myself holding a piece of
fan art i made
you made it twice how about that amazing
i'm sorry jack's microphone i'm sorry
i have a small microphone now so i can't
deep throat it i swear
i will not do it i promise
what have i become my sweetest friend
everyone i know
somewhere
i have headache i am tired but with you
done
i did it boss i did the video thank you
for watching
smash like subscribe 100 106 million
subscribers
can we get it are we are we close i
think i'm the only one that knows
oh [ __ ] we hit 106. i didn't even know
why did no one tell me yeah they mean
this means we add another tambourine
to tower of tambury at last
at last finally
all right tomorrow although i got to
order tonight i gotta get it i gotta go
i gotta go again tonight thank you for
106.
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean